welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how to take
out the big bad armored gods who keep
meddling in all of our businesses like
on a genetic level they should probably
stop because uh i really would like to
have hair i don't know what this is
about but okay celestials what are you
doing my name is mt and i'm here today
with my off-screen producer brandon
buddy brother brandon it's a brandon
twice what's going on
a name's so nice you had to say it twice
empty seriously so happy to be here so
sorry that your god has forsaken you and
left you without hair it's terrible and
he should be destroyed i've had this
famine for too long brandon i need the
crops to grow all right geez
hit me with that uh
less bald big question brandon because
you have a very beautiful head of hair
oh thank you empty here's a fully haired
question for you that sounds terrible
well mt you know eternals is finally out
we've waited so long and finally we get
to see the celestials for real in the
mcu you know we saw him a little bit uh
as like a little caricature but like
this is the real stuff we got some good
looks at him oh yeah and boy was it
awesome they look so huge so scary big
booming voices it was just great and we
know that they love to like kill off
planets willy-nilly uh you know they've
got they got to create worlds they got a
whole big picture thing they're working
on but you know i want to live okay
don't be killing my planet
i'd rather not die ideally you know it
looks like going forward our heroes are
gonna have to deal with these cosmic
threats who are probably now a little
pissed off uh that we started meddling
in their business so that leads us all
to this week's big question mt
how do you kill a celestial
brandon why are you interested in this
do you have like debts like do you have
beef with a celestial yes yes i have
beef with um
markov the debtor uh and
he's he's calling in my loans and i i
can't i can't do it right now okay my
least favorite celestial sallie mae
son of a [ __ ]
well brandon killing our big bad cosmic
daddies isn't easy just like pimping
pimping isn't easy either
but as the eternal
but as the eternals film and the library
of marvel comics has shown us it can
certainly be done but just how do you do
it well let's dive into the research and
find out so that we can kill celestials
on our spare time because sweet uh screw
those guys they uh they're real jerks
honestly but before we start we have to
ask what are celestials
wait a minute
who are you
because we have to establish you know a
base understanding of exactly what these
creatures are what these beings are
before we talk about them but
essentially the celestials are these
nigh immortal beings that were created
at the very beginning of the universe
and they are generally pretty freaking
huge standing at over 2000 feet tall
which is you know just like just like me
i'm like i'm around like nine thousand
nine hundred ninety five feet tall but
you know give it to almost there almost
there you know guys like to lie about
their height but not me um i'm around
there though the largest one exatar is
around 20 000 feet tall so you know he
drank his milk he's a big boy up there
he drank all of the milk and all of the
doors i'd like to think that it was uh
the blue milk from um h2 from
episode 8 luke skywalker blue milk and
they're obviously clad in brightly
colored armor and is generally unknown
what they look like underneath that
armor however in the case of ego the
living planet he looks like a planet
with like you know a brain inside which
you know pretty self-explanatory
and of course the celestials create
alter and monitor life throughout the
cosmos and though their intentions and
machinations cannot be comprehended and
they are an enigma to all of us you may
be an open book spongebob but i'm a bit
more complicated than that
the inner machinations of my mind are an
enigma
[Music]
they generally seem to be obsessed with
the evolution of life throughout the
universe like life is the name of the
game for the celestial race and they
love showing up on planets experimenting
on the dominant life form and sprinkling
in a dash of eternals and deviants to
really screw things up because i mean
surviving was already hard enough just
add some deviants to determine why not
right
we're trying our best celestials just
like give us a break okay we're trying
to ooga booga in peace we don't need all
these superhero shits just all up in our
business smashing rocks over here leave
us alone right
and then of course the celestials wait a
couple eons and then show back up and go
i don't want to play with this planet
anymore and then squash us like a bug
it's rude it's so rude don't be
rude are you kidding me and in the mcu
it has been established in eternals that
they like to create worlds throughout
the universe and love to plant little
celestial baby eggs inside of those
planets that feed off the energy
generated by sentient life on the
surface and then once they get enough of
that sweet life milk
they hatch out of their planetary egg
killing off everyone and then you know
go about their business because you got
to keep moving i mean you can't you
can't cry over spilt uh billions of
lives yeah yeah just yeah keep moving
you know you can't you can't create
universes empty without cracking a few
trillion life eggs just dead just dead
that's how you make a that omelette
would be uh quite delicious
sadly delicious the saddest most
delicious omelette ever had it's a
denver omelet made of denver it's it's
tasty yum yum yum right denver is
actually in the um it is like jeez and
not a lot of eggs have a hint of beyonce
in it and they are extremely extremely
hard to kill of course and they can
regenerate limbs
heal each other and even just one
surviving celestial can regenerate an
entire race like that is a lot of power
and because of their immortality they
view their work on a pretty grand scale
of time because i mean it makes sense
because time is relative to who's
experiencing the time so us we live
these
short longish lives of 100 years to a
celestial that's like a minute that's
like a second honestly it's like what is
a hundred years yeah which is why ego
left meredith he was like hey i'll be
back it's like it'll be like fine you'll
be fine he's like quit bugging me about
leaving the toilet seat up okay all
right i got it
way way beyond this conversation right
now okay meredith just give me a break
i like to think that ego thought like
peter was around potty training time
like by the time he showed up he's like
oh no dad i'm actually in my 30s he was
like oh shoot you guys age that fast
that's weird she's like she's like
making him watch like the love boat and
he's like i'm gonna
blow up this place
this is so dumb can't wait to cover this
planet in my goo
i hate this yes so celestials view their
work on a pretty grand scale of time
most of the time so the worries are
concerns of some pathetically mortal
beings don't really matter to them
because it sort of makes sense and the
work that they do goes way beyond
anything we can even comprehend so we
can stop crying about our world being
destroyed already because we're just
being big babies about it huge babies
they got they got work to do okay they
can't listen to every single living
thing okay and plus like we'd be
formulating like a huge mega megazord
like imagine being part of a megazord
that's you know
kind of doing
planetary genocide on the regular but at
least you'd be a megazord that's pretty
cool that's pretty cool and in the
comics the celestials were actually
responsible for the multiverse well
originally there was only one universe
and the celestials were created in
service of the universe and that
universe was called the first firmament
and that is the first ever multiverse in
the world but some celestials rebelled
because they wanted to make their own
life and then shattered that first
universe into a second universe
[Applause]
and these are the multi-colored
celestials that we know of the most
today and as they were having this
little rebellion that the little busting
tea party on a grand scale they had to
kill off a couple of loyalist celestials
because that's how war works so that
leads us to our first way to kill a
celestial just be a celestial wow
because you know if humans can kill
humans celestials can kill celestial
when are we gonna address the rampant
problem of celestial on celestial crime
empty right someone's gotta stop it it's
all this rap music brandon i'm telling
you they're listening to this hardcore
celestial rap talking about blowing up
stars making all these black holes i
don't know what they're talking about
man it is kind of crazy that like the
multicolored celestials that like we
fear they were like kind of the cool
young hip guys who were like hey let's
go make some life and then they did do
it and now we're mad at them and they're
like hey we were once the cool ones okay
why you mad at us now you wouldn't even
be here if it wasn't for us it's like
parents that were jerks that expect you
to be grateful
why are you guys beating babies
turtles kill you all but also you can
get your hands on some god killer armor
which is basically this giant ship made
from celestial armor that was used in
the original celestial war that you know
tony stark got to mess around with in
his series for a little bit but there's
more than one way to kill your average
armored space god so let's check out
some other ways that these cosmic giants
have been cut down and what better way
to start with than an axe because axes
can cut things down i hear i don't go
outside much but i hear that uh real men
who know how to you know do manual labor
that's an axe they chop down trees and
one of the strongest axes in the marvel
universe is an axe called yarnborn
yarnbjorn yarnbjorn is a mythical axe
that was forged by dwarves many
centuries ago and it has a really long
and complicated history of owners but
more importantly it was wielded by four
in the 9th century before he was worthy
enough to wield mjolnir and thor winds
up blessing it with his own blood giving
it the ability to pierce celestial armor
and then winds up getting passed down
from the asgardian armory to baron
mordo's tomb and then gets wielded by
people like kane the conqueror which you
know that's the best person to have that
axe and the apocalypse twins which i i
hope they held the axes uh together
together
like twins we're twins
we do everything together apocalypse yay
and they actually do end up using
yarnbjorn to kill a celestial gardener
and celestial gardeners are the
celestials that actually go around
planting these life seeds onto new
worlds so you know killing a celestial
gardener that's a big deal yeah absolute
celestials anyway it's good for everyone
else but eventually yarmbjorn winds up
in the hands of roona a valkyrie for
whom yarmbjorn was originally created
all those centuries ago she then uses
yarmborn to kill the physical form of
the headless celestial so if you have a
mythical acts of prophecy that is
enchanted by thor's blood you might have
a chance of taking down a celestial but
wait what about that headless celestial
luna took down
yeah about that
a celestial without a head that seems
crazy empty
how could there be a celeste show of
that ahead i didn't even hurt
that that would mean the celestial's
head would be floating around in space
somewhere are you saying this is a is it
a nearly headless celestial how could
you be nearly headless um
like this
but yeah empty how did this celestial
become headless in the first place well
brandon the eldris god of darkness no
didn't really take too kindly to being
plucked from the darkness between you
know the sixth and seventh cosmos and
being examined by a celestial not really
a great thing to be plucked by a space
gun it's a it's a funny thing to imagine
though it's really funny yeah
i love what's one thing i really like
about celestials is like they physically
will just grab people and pick them up
like they didn't have live it's like all
right you're mine now all right thank
you you know 99.9 of the time most
people don't do anything but right no he
he didn't really like that because the
celestial was like hey what the hell is
this thing what is what is this thing it
just picked him up and was like yeah no
thank you and then put him back and then
no being the god of darkness also wasn't
too keen on these celestials going
around you know making light right and
life all over the place he wanted
darkness
yeah this is what malaka's whole deal
was in for the dark world he's like what
is up with all this light turn the
lights off man i'm trying to go to sleep
he's like i hate you dad i just want to
be in my room i want to listen to my
music i blacked out my curtains you just
want to listen to his emo music yeah
yeah i dye my hair black dad don't ask
questions you don't get it you don't get
me dad he's got his eyeliner on yeah god
this eyeliner is actually dark matter
okay dad okay
okay
this is my life now okay i don't care i
don't need a i don't need a job i don't
need a career um no
then mrs kitt is like oh no what are we
gonna do our son
he's out of control our baby boy is the
god of darkness because that is like i'm
kind of proud a little bit but he's out
of control and so nal ends up forging a
sword from his own shadow a sword that
would be the very first symbiote aka
venom's first ancestor and then chopped
off the celestial's head that was
touching him all weird so take that god
that's what you get that's what you get
never touch me without consent it's true
it's true what happens and then that
sword that he used to chop down the
celestial would be known as the all
black and that decapitated head would
become known as nowhere which we saw in
the mcu as the collector's home base of
the tavon group his little group of uh
people that like to mine and steal [ __ ]
well that's your [ __ ] still people still
people human beings well they steal some
[ __ ] but they definitely steal some
people
so you know be an eldritch god and get
your hands on the necro sword and you
might have a chance at killing a
celestial okay but you know maybe if
that's a little bit too hard don't worry
i got another option for you okay let's
hear it the [ __ ] the one
because you know another way a celestial
can be taken down is with an insect-like
species known as the horde and the horde
was created by the fulcrum to sort of
you know balance out all the
life-creating that the celestials were
doing in the universe and they are this
devastating force of destruction you
know essentially this huge cosmic plague
of locus and life itself was the field
of wheat that they were going to feast
on and they mainly show up to clean up
the planet's life energy if the deviant
species becomes the dominant life form
over the base species that the eternals
were meant to keep on top and the uh
okay and the horde were able to infest
the celestial progenitor and kill him
completely and then that body fell to
earth and then his celestial fluids
leaks onto our planet and actually loki
claims that this is why earth is full of
so many superpowered inhabitants because
it's all the celestial goo that seeped
out of a dead celestial that was
murdered by the horde that's a really
that's a really cool idea that's that's
very smart i mean that's a smart way to
explain why every planet doesn't just
have all these like super powered heroes
it's like well earth got a little you
know extra when that celestial died on
it and
his blood and guts seeped into our dirt
and here we are now but the cavemen were
going ooka booga and all of a sudden one
of them was like going ooga booga and
lifting up a giant rock and they're like
what's going on here ooga booga orton
that is the question that is the
question and that's human sentience but
it's really interesting to see how
celestial biology has changed humanity
in this way because if you remember in
guardians of the galaxy the collector is
selling all of this you know the this
mined celestial goo and organs that he's
mined from this nowhere creature and
selling them on the cosmic black market
so if human beings on marvel earth were
super powered and extra special because
of this goo imagine how much that goo is
[ __ ] up the entirety of the mcu
cosmic scale that's a great point empty
because they never really explain what
they're doing with those like open pits
of goo and guardians of the galaxy you
know it's just
drax gets to fall into it it's a fun
little bit yeah but like that would be
very cool too if that comes back later
if drax whatever he goes up against in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 if it is a
celestial if all of a sudden they're
like drax you're covered in celestial
goo you can take these bad boys out now
and he's like hell yeah let's go
yeah and now i'm actually the destroyer
let's get it but he also takes a bath in
a different type of goo the little
tentacled monster goo and guardians
that's right so i wonder because like
now he has this two cosmic blood goo
running through his system i wonder if
that's like gonna affect anything and
like hey apparently at the beginning of
eternals we learned that the celestials
are technically not native to this
universe they came here before the
singularities before the creation of the
universe so technically the celestials
are also multi-dimensional beings so he
drax has double the interdimensional goo
within his system but of course speaking
of guardians too of course in the mcu we
saw the celestial ego was killed by a
bomb to the brain as most bombs will do
if you plant a bomb on your brain do not
try this on home children do not an ego
is kind of a outlier in this case and
snt wasn't the traditional armored
celestial that is more common and that
we you know know the most remember that
we don't know what celestials look like
under that armor but in the mcu if you
could somehow get to whatever the brain
is under that armor and put a bomb there
you could theoretically kill a celestial
yeah that makes a lot of sense them too
because
we know that celestials must have some
sort of brain they're obviously thinking
they can speak and all that kind of
stuff
and they're doing all this planning so
if you could get under the armor somehow
and get to a brain that seems to be a
constant so far right chopped off head
you know that's how you get rid of a
celestial you got to get to that big
brain that big celestial brain brains
that dome get that celestial dome bro
always go for the head you know what i'm
saying
that's right you should have gone for
the dead
dumbass
i would love if that'll say something
like really funny he's like i got you
[ __ ]
gotcha [ __ ]
i mean we do have some type of idea
about what's under the celestial army
because like
nowhere is a skeletal head that's true
so like we do know that the celestials
to some extent have a skeletal structure
at the very least
so like they have a lot of the tissues
that we have there's essentially just
larger more powerful versions of us you
know but we don't exactly know what they
look like
yeah yeah there was i was reading there
was one comic where a celestial kind of
took his helmet off but it was just like
bright white light you know you didn't
see anything so it's who knows yeah in
the comics they're more just like this
ethereal just like we're just lights
yeah and it's also whoever's writing the
comic arc and you know it could be a
different you know if it's not earth 616
they they can be a little more loosely
goosey because they're like well that's
just this dimension they they kind of
act like this yeah and like because the
celestials are so purposely vague
throughout all of marvel comics they're
just like do whatever you want with
celestials really it's fine that's fine
and of course in eternals we saw how
cersei was able to harness the power of
the unimine to enhance her transmutation
powers in order to turn tiamat into
marble which is you know great for a
museum and this could mean that more
eternal spread throughout the universe
could have the power to kill off more
celestials and you know though as eric
theorized in his eternal breakdown
tiamat may have okayed his stoning since
you know he too was linked up to the
unimine and yeah he seemed to have some
type of affinity towards the planet and
the humans that lived on it maybe or
maybe he was just tired and he's like i
don't want to wake up
baby he's like they sent me the email
before like a day before i'm just like
not about all this working stuff he's
like well can i have a few billion more
years so sorry i'm not ready right
so guys it's like five more billion
years it's an alarm clock he sneezes it
i mean it is our life force and
consciousness and we're pretty lazy
sometimes so maybe it's just like being
us
and then of course finally there is one
more way to kill celestial that we
should consider you just call up his
boss the big daddy the big honcho that's
right the one above all should have the
power to eliminate celestial with just
the stroke of their pen one above all is
the ultimate power in the marvel
universe so if you absolutely have to
take out a celestial just go karen on
his ass and go speak to the manager
that's right he'll do it he will fire a
celestial real quick fired
because i know you brought up the
fulcrum earlier uh mt and some people
think the fulcrum is the one above all
it's hard to tell they're both these
weird kind of creative forces above the
universe right and in theory the one
above all that creates everything
created the celestials if you can get in
touch with the one above all if you're
thor and you're in the mcu and you can
call kevin feige somehow boom you can
kill any last show you want super easy
barely an inconvenience oh really i hear
that uh if you use linkedin well enough
you can get to the one above all dude if
you can figure out linkedin you must be
a celestial i mean it's the most
comfortable i have never been able to
figure out
linkedin it's it's impossible i'm like
what is this weird
adult boring
lame facebook what is this what is this
every couple weeks i'll like be like
okay i'm gonna address all these
linkedin emails i've been getting hit
notifications and i'll spend 20 minutes
on there and i'm just like there's blood
coming out of my eyes and i'm like
what's happening i don't understand bro
i i never want to ever seriously use
linkedin in my life sorry if we ever use
linkedin as a sponsorship but [ __ ] that
[ __ ] they're not gonna
sponsor us now empty i'll tell you that
right now
they'll be like who are these dumb
non-career-minded idiots linked out
empty there was another person you were
bringing up that we were kind of talking
about before the show who has maybe
killed a celestial or at least really
wants to kill a celestial oh my god okay
so one of my favorite ways that you can
kill celestial is through one of my
favorite marvel characters ever
stellaris marvel if you're watching this
introduce to laras to the mcu because
dolares is literally a celestial hunter
i think she's actually killed celestials
in the past and she goes around with
this pink celestial armor like she's
literally decked out in like celestial
level armor and she goes out to fight
celestial she almost killed a celestial
one time but actually through her power
she actually accidentally led to the
birth of a celestial which is a the
opposite of what she was trying to do
but in the comics she actually teams up
with nebula at one point she's a really
cool character very obscure but like she
can technically have the has the power
or like has the confidence in herself at
the very least to kill celestial so
confidence is all you need so it sounds
like you know it is possible to kill
these celestials you just got to be
super powerful have some sort of like
powerful enchanted weapon or be able to
like get past the armor which is the
hardest part to do but you can do it
they can be killed it can be done so we
hope that this episode a big question
comes in handy should you ever come in
face with a celestial and you know you
need to take him out because sometimes
it happens it happens you know you never
know who's going to be your enemy in
life it could be god you got to be a big
guy it could be god you never know but
hey guys there is a new latest obsession
shirt over at newrockstarsmerch.com
inspired by the eternals called immortal
unity and you need to go check it out
right now it's an incredible design and
it's a limited edition meaning that it
will only be around for a set amount of
time that is what limited edition means
welcome to 2021 boom so you can get it
in black or navy and they've got sizes
up to 4xl so grab some early christmas
gifts for your nerdy loved ones or treat
yourself to some cool t-shirts buddies
stickers and more at
newrockstarsmerch.com new rockstars.com
just do it just by the stuff just do it
and before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from the
people that helped bring big question to
you people like draftkings what an nfl
season it has been so far and it's only
getting better so get in on all the
actions still to come with draftkings
the official daily fantasy partner of
the nfl and this week new customers can
play free for millions with their first
deposit and don't miss your first shot
to get some skin in the pigskin game so
playing daily fantasy football is simple
just pick up your lineup of the nfl
stars while staying under the salary cap
and score enough points to bring home
some sweet sweet moolah and with a free
shot at millions of dollars in total
prizes you'll feel the nfl action like
never before and draftkings is safe
secure and reliable and best of all you
can deposit and withdraw your cash
whenever you want they're flexible like
that so download the draftkings app now
and use the promo code big question to
play free for millions that's right
enter promo code big question to get a
free shot of millions in total prizes
with your first deposit and do not miss
out download draftkings today and play
with the official daily fantasy partner
of the nfl minimum 5 deposit required
eligibility restrictions apply see
draftkings.com for details what would
you do if you didn't have high interest
loans or credit card debt probably smile
with upstar you can pay off your
existing debt quickly and easily and
start living your life upstart is the
fast and easy way to pay off your debt
with a personal loan all online whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over a million
people have used upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date rather than looking at
credit score alone upstart considers
other factors like your income current
employment and credit history to find
you a smarter rate for your loan you can
check your rate without impacting your
credit score in minutes for loans
between one thousand to fifty thousand
dollars you can even receive funds as
fast as one business day after accepting
your loan find out how upstart can lower
your monthly payments today when you go
to upstart.com bigquestion that's
upstart.com bigquestion don't forget to
use our url to let them know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application upstart.com bigquestion all
right brandon are you ready for this
it's time for the by test question let's
get ready to rumble
it'll just be silently bouncing like
right
it's like what is empty doing it's like
a fpc dial
what's wrong with these senile people
well brandon our first bite size
question of the day is why isn't kylo
ren a darth like why isn't he darth red
and this is from lopsided frames on
twitter thank you lopsided frames i hope
you never get those frames adjusted
keep them lopsided keep them quirky
that's how people know you gangsta well
well my friends you know in the star
wars universe okay the whole darth thing
was a title used by the sith the sith
are of course force wielders who focus
on using the dark side of the force and
the sith they loved to follow that rule
of two philosophy this meant there were
only ever two sith a master and an
apprentice and when you became like an
apprentice you got that darth title and
this helped keep this rule of two helped
keep the sith existing in the shadows
underneath the watchful eye of the jedi
council who wanted to wipe them out
completely and they thought they had
kind of done it you know we all saw the
phantom menace they're like
they haven't been sifted in forever you
idiots the sith have been extinct for a
millennial i
do not believe the sith could have
returned without us knowing
idiots we will never die what are you
talking about come on
so dumb so dumb the jedi are dumb that's
what i'm saying the jedi are dumb so
darth was like a title you earned when
you became a sith uh you know there was
darth plagious darth sidious darth vader
etc and the rule of two does seem like
very very strange because it means that
you have to like constantly watch your
back so that the other sith doesn't kill
you uh but you can't argue with the
results okay palpatine did successfully
take over the galactic republic and wipe
out most of the jedi and he formed the
empire boom so uh you have to spend your
whole life worrying that your student is
going to kill you your student is
worried that you're going to kill him
and then you're a student you're trying
to get your own student and you're going
to be like hey we're going to kill the
other guy don't worry about it it's cool
it's very tough to be a sith so it's
basically high school it's basically
high school it's very similar minus two
plus two equals
i'll break your neck
zero i was like my math teacher is going
to kill me i know it i'm gonna get him
first
however when when vader tossed you know
daddy palpatine over
over the edge and killed him it pretty
much wiped out the sith and ended the
darth title ring because when he does
that you know when dreadfighter does
that darth vader dies he goes back to
being anakin and then he dies again uh
and then he gets to come back as a force
ghost and then george lucas is like i'm
gonna replace the actor and put hayden
christiansen in there and then the
actor's like what everyone will love
this
changing it just let it go let it go
george let me go george please
go
my shun
leave me
no
you're coming with me that's that's
return of the jedi talking to georgie
just let me die george please george
stop stop changing me so the real reason
that kylo ren isn't a darth is because
he wasn't isn't really a sith he was
playing around with the dark side but
not every dark side force user was a
sith there was other factions of like
dark side users so the sith don't really
exist anymore so that's kind of why he's
not a darth so for example there were
the knights of ren they had and they had
emerged as this like squad of like dark
side users ben solo's like hating what
he's learning at the jedi academy with
uncle luke he's like this [ __ ] sucks
and you know the knights of ren are
there and they're using the dark side
and there's more than two of them so
they're not doing the whole rule of two
thing right and the knights of rand they
had a leader called guess it ren that's
why the they were the knights around ren
stevens from even stevens yeah it was
ren stephens
i'd follow her anywhere christy carlson
romano if you're out there call me don't
call me i'm married we can talk we can
have a conversation that's why we got
into youtube to hit on christy carlson
i just got canceled
so ben solo you know he kind of rejected
luke and his teachings and the knights
of ren are kind of like working for
snoke and then ben solo's like i'm gonna
fight you ren and ren and ben solo fight
and benzela kills him and so then
snoke's like okay you could lead the
night to ren now and ben solo's like
okay well i need a new name so i'm gonna
be kylo ren so that's where kylo ren
came from and like snoke never gave kylo
a darth title either even i don't know
if like snoke i might be wrong in this i
don't think snoke was very sity he was
kind of sith sith light you know because
palpatine's telling snoke what to do the
like kind of reanimated corpse of
palpatine but snoke is just a pawn
snoke's a chump he's chump change so and
then when kylo kills snoke and like kind
of rejects everything that any that
exists out there there's no way he's
going to be a darth at all so that's
kind of why kylo ren is in a darth v the
darth is they're done with darths darth
darth is old school that's it it's just
one part of the dark side it's just one
dark side religion out of any that you
could have if if you have you know years
of your life to throw away get into that
expanded star wars universe there's so
much out there for you to discover i'm
not dissing anyone who likes it it's
great stuff but i don't have the time
yeah i definitely have not got into the
whole extended universe i mainly started
after the marvel uh picked it up in 2015
but there's a whole there's decades
worth of extended universe stuff that is
just pretty wild so cool stories out
there great cool comic books really cool
dark side users really cool light side
users but yeah that's that's why kylo is
in a darth because he's just a kylo okay
all right i like how he called himself
red after the duty killed he's like you
know what respect i'm around i'm gonna
respect you i'm you now i'm wearing your
face
is that letter looks like i should have
killed this boy he's like oh there's
something wrong with my nephew man jesus
christ alright brandon i got another
question for you how is spider-man able
to stick to stuff if he's wearing
spandex over his hands that's kind of
weird like what did he need finger
tipless gloves and this is from of
course i ajsmith24 discord hi aj smith
thank you very much always holding it
down yes thank you and man
i have been
waiting for this question okay
we had this long talk in the office not
too long ago give me some ice in a
styrofoam bucket
here we go
back when we did the episode where we
talked about toby's tubes uh uh this we
we talked about this too and so i'm glad
i get to talk about this now okay
because if you remember we were talking
about you know toby mcguire's spider-man
they don't explain the web shooters and
said he just has like tubes inside of
his body pushing webbing around through
glands who knows it's disgusting but so
this idea that this idea that spider-man
has like little tiny hairs on his
fingers or on his toes or on his body or
whatever to stick to walls that's like
an invention for the sam raimi
spider-man movies you know just like how
they wanted to an easy way to explain
the web they didn't want to show that
like oh toby maguire peter parker builds
these web shooters and also the formula
for webbing instead they were just like
oh he wakes up and webbing's coming out
of his body don't ask questions you're
moviegoers again it's it's like 2001
comic book movies are just starting to
really ramp up again you know and so
they needed easy ways to explain things
to audiences
and they're very and i think this was
very clever there's a shot in the in the
same roomy spider-man where you see a
close-up of his finger and you see these
little barbs these little microscopic
hairs and as an audience goer who maybe
you understand spider-man as a concept
but you never really thought about how
it works this kind of makes sense right
oh he can stick to walls that makes a
lot of sense but when you start thinking
about it he puts the gloves on and
you're like okay well maybe it's going
through the gloves but what about his
feet right you know he's right the hairs
can't go through your shoes it can't go
the soles of the shoes so how is that
working they don't explain that in the
movie you know i would love to see if
his little toes popped out of my shoes
like spiderman wearing like uh
fingerless gloves and like sandals would
be the silliest thing i've ever seen in
my life be like who's this hippie
climbing walls
so in the comics the way that spider-man
is able to crawl has nothing to do with
like little hairs it's moroccan
it's sorry sorry mt
it's more akin to the concept of like
static electricity there's this
chemistry term known as i gotta look at
it as
van der waals forces and that's
basically explains the attraction and
repulsion between atoms and so there are
some animals and like smaller insects
and like geckos and stuff they're
they're able to crawl vertical surfaces
because of this kind of like static
electric field they create it's way too
sciency for me to understand but that's
basically how it works and in the
official handbook of the marvel universe
which originally started by was started
by editor-in-chief of marvel jim shooter
back in 1982 it states in that handbook
that spider-man can enhance the
inter-atomic attractive forces on
surfaces he touches increasing the
coefficient of friction between the
surface and himself and peter parker
kind of thinks like this is like a thing
he does with his mind it's it's a result
of the radioactive spider bite so it's
not little hairs it's basically he's
manipulating kind of like
this static electric void between him
and the wall and that's how he creates
like his sickness crazy like look guys
it's comic books you know there's going
to be a little suspension of disbelief
but the little hairs doesn't make any
sense
so
he's manipulating these cosmic voids of
static electricity but it works and he's
climbing walls baby okay you sure is oh
man so like that gets me thinking about
uh miles morales powers because like we
know that miles morales runs on this
form of like bio electricity that he can
shoot out of his body so i wonder if
peter has that to like a little small
extent yeah maybe it's just like the the
stats are more turned up there for miles
morales than they are for peter that's
why he's able to like shoot out the
actual electricity that actually makes a
lot of sense empty that's so interesting
thank you brandon i had no idea well
you're very welcome i'm so glad that
question got asked because it was a big
argument here in the office
like two people died it was pretty bad
yes me and editor john almost came to
blows it was dangerous all right now it
is time for my favorite part of the show
it's time for the boxers crap the box is
crazy
i'm just reading back subscribe
all right man i got a question for you
if you were a celestial what would be
your role in the cosmos like what would
be your celestial name because we have
aaron the judge right s and the searcher
what would be your role okay for me mt i
would be brandor the taster okay i agree
this huge bang
brandor would have like
really cool bright purple cosmic armor
like very dangerous right and i'd choke
in the sky on your planet and i'd be
like give me your food and i would soak
up all the different like delicacies
from around your planet and i would
taste them and based on that taste i
would judge your planet and if the
tastes
of your regional culinary delights were
sufficient to my formula which i have
written on my tongue okay your planet
would be spared but if your food tastes
like doo doo
boom
you're like the guy fieri of celestia
yes
you're just going around your freaking
car it's like all right go to this dude
i'm diners drive-ins and dimensions okay
ciders drive in and die
you better take me to flavor town or i'm
squashing your planet okay that's all i
gotta say
so earth would be fine because we have
cheese and that's all i need i just need
a lot of cheese totally fine here we go
what about you mt what is your cosmic
role
i that's oh man that's that one's hard
to beat because i just imagined you like
as a celestial looking through someone's
window like while they're eating it like
a family meal just being like are you
gonna finish that
give me your nachos
i'd like to be like empty the comforter
because like they're not the celestial
for like being nice to people so i just
show up just be like hey man
uh i don't know what do you guys need
i'll listen to your problems i don't
know
you're the one that comes in so airship
shows up and he's like i'm going to
judge you i'll be back in the millennia
and then you come in like right after
we're like whoa guys that was pretty
crazy huh i know right that was a lot if
you guys need anyone to talk to you what
do you think you guys want to chat you
want to watch a movie or something so
sorry i know we're scary i'm sorry what
color armor would you like empty what
would be your color you know what i i
would go i would go purple oh i would
probably go we're both purple baby let's
do it let's go oh wait you're purple too
wait i can't use your purple okay no no
i would go hmm
i'll go red then i'll get red celestial
i like that but then that's aeroshoe
damn it yeah there's only so many colors
empty it's not your fault i know
damn it all right if airship isn't mad
i'll be red yeah yeah you could be a red
also it's okay empty the comforter and
brandon the what was it the brand or the
taster the taste the taster brandor the
taster we're gonna be homies we're gonna
be best friends yes we're like
i think we're that's huge hufflepuff
energy i feel like
just tasting and just being nice
i just want that food but that is it for
this episode of big question i want to
thank brandon of course for joining me
this episode please follow him at
grindenberric on twitter if you want to
see him tweet some great things he's an
amazing man i love him to death please
follow him there and of course you can
follow me at mastertainment but more
importantly you can follow us at new
rockstars on twitter and on youtube and
make sure you hit that notification bell
so you get notifications every time we
upload a video and also make sure you
hit up newrockstoremerge.com so you get
cool shirts like this and all of our
other cool stickers and all of our fun
nerd stuff um literally it's the best
place for nerds so please go to
rockstarsmerch.com we love you guys
thank you guys for watching we'll see
you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you